Gregory Johnson machine learning
scientists and the Allen Institute for
cell science
or excellent labels are the primary
means by which we can see where certain
structures are inside of the cell and
this is especially useful for live cell
imaging one of the major problems of
this is that due to technological
limitations we can only see a handful of
labelled structures at the same time
reasons for that are many fluorescent
labels disturb the natural processes of
the cell or when we try to cause these
fluorescent labels to fluoresce that
interrogation of the cell
Costa cell it's part of a classic
the types of images that we're
collecting here are extraordinarily
sophisticated unlike normal images these
images are both type series several
movies but they're also
three-dimensional and they carry a lot
of information about what's going on and
this information is often very difficult
for human beings to interpret and so
when we have to use machine learning
models to allow us to easily integrate
all been together
one of the things that we're trying to
do is build models that are as useful
for scientists as possible and that
involves taking the type of experiments
that they can run in a in a very cheap
way and use them to predict the outcome
of very expensive experiments and that
sort of sort of two purposes one of
those purposes is to sort of reduce the
burden and experimentation for
scientists and the other purpose is to
be able to allow the scientist of the
hypotheses using these models for them
to understand where the most valuable
experiments that they could be running
in the future